>>Karen: Good morning, Dianelys.
>>Dianelys: Good morning, Karen.
Good morning, Angell.
>>Angel: Good morning, Dianelys.
>>Valerie Gallagher: I think
before any learning can take place,
the students really need to feel
safe, feel like they're seen,
and feel like they're cared about.
The impact I see from morning meeting
is that classes are true communities.
We're learning from each other's
strengths, we're helping each other.
It's a foundation for
everything that comes after.
>>Students: Good morning, Ms. Gallagher.
>>Valerie Gallagher: Morning
meetings are a really important part
of the responsive classroom model,
which we use here throughout
Highlander Charter School.
It's a chance for the students to make
that transition from home to school.
It's a way for everyone to settle in and
feel that they're a part of a community.
>>Monica: It puts me in
a focused and good mood.
It makes me feel ready to learn.
>>Dan Baldassi: So, welcome.
I'm so excited to see you guys today.
>>Dan Baldassi: Our morning
meeting lasts about fifteen minutes
and we have four parts
that we do together.
Each classroom might be a little
different the way the teacher runs it.
We start with our greeting.
The kids choose what their
greeting is for that day
that helps them want to participate.
>>Student: Good morning, Apple.
>>Student: Good morning, Analise.
>>Valerie Gallagher:
We make eye contact.
We're having our ears, our eyes and
our brain on the person who's speaking.
>>Student: Good morning, Benjamin.
>>Jane Picciotti: "How
are you feeling today?
Are you ready to learn?"
If you're not ready to learn,
what can we do to get you there?
>>Dianelys: After the
greeting, we do share.
I like it when people share because
we get to know them a little better.
>>Jamarie: There's like a
little board and whoever went,
you have to check them off and you have
to say what you did on the weekend.
>>Student: I went to the movie.
>>Student: What was is in the movie?
>>Student: When they died--
>>Valerie Gallagher: We've had
a lot of interesting issues come
up through shares, whether it be
deaths in the family, politics
and people feeling safe or
not safe because of that--
you know, things you might not normally
talk about in a first-grade classroom.
Morning meeting gives you the space and
the time to have those conversations.
>>Students: Today my
grandparents are coming.
I'm ready for questions and comments.
>>Valerie Gallagher: They
get to answer questions.
"Somebody cares about me.
All these hands are interested in me."
>>Student: Didn't they come last time?
>>Student: Yeah, but they had to go back
because something happened
in their country.
>>Marcella: Morning meeting
makes me feel calm and happy.
My favorite part is the glitter jar.
>>Dan Baldassi: We shake the glitter
jar, we put it in the middle.
The kids have a moment to watch.
>>Adrian: Mr. B puts the
timer on for a minute.
We reflect on what we can do to
get yourself ready for the day.
>>Monica: Today we got to think about
how you can be helpful to your friends.
>>Dan Baldassi: So, is there
someone who would like to share?
Chrisana.
>>Chrisana: If somebody's sad,
you can help them feel
better by playing with them.
>>Dan Baldassi: Okay, I like that.
Nice job.
Dianelys: After the
share, we get to do a game.
>>Student: One, two-- Dianelys:
Someone counts without looking
and people go into corners--
>>Student: -- nine, ten!
Corner number three!
>>Valerie Gallagher: Oh!
>>Student: One, two--
>>Valerie Gallagher: It really gives
them a chance to get that last burst
of energy out before
it's time for them to sit
down to the serious business
of literacy.
>>Student: Corner number one.
>>Valerie Gallagher: Ooh!
>>Valerie Gallagher: Then after
that I go over the agenda every day,
knowing what's going to happen
next is really important to kids.
>>Valerie Gallagher: After that is-- ?
>>Students: PE!
>>Valerie Gallagher: Then
we get to eat our-- ?
>>Students: Lunch!
>>Valerie Gallagher: Then
we're going to have some-- ?
>>Students: Math power!
>>Valerie Gallagher: So
that kind of sets the tone.
We're here together, morning meeting.
We know what's going on with everyone.
We're ready to go.
>>Dan Baldassi: So, I know fifteen
minutes can sometimes be a hard thing
to try to put in your schedule,
but students in each classroom know
that they're coming into safe places.
This is a chance for them to
have voice in their classroom.
>>Jane Picciotti: It's about respecting
each other, respecting your teacher.
It's rooted in positive interactions.
It definitely helps set our culture.
>>Adrian: I think it wouldn't be
as easy to do the rest of the day.
It helps me a lot.